[Musique]
il
mais
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau vais y telle émission nous
découvrent des personnalités yvelinoise
je me trouve en compagnie d' adama
sissoko bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
ini monteyne et vous avez écrit un roman
qui s'appelle l'insignifiante qu'on peut
voir juste ici vous y raconter une
partie de votre vie puisque à peine
diplômé d'une école de commerce vous
décrocher un poste dans l'hôtellerie aux
états unis dans la ville de baltimore un
plus précisément au nord-est du pays
alors quitter votre ville natale
nanterre pour baltimore c'était vraiment
une aventure une belle aventure oui oui
oui sachant qu'en plus alors c'est
vraiment une opportunité qui arrive est
complètement par hasard et puis je
partais pour les états unis nous qu'on a
tous une image des états unis qui est ce
qu'elle est avec les films
particulièrement de new york alors
c'était marrant c'est que baltimore
c'était juste à côté de new york donc ce
n'était pas le même cadre que j'allais
retrouver et donc je suis parti vraiment
sans me poser de questions je me suis
dit on va voir ce qui va se passer je
suis parti assez sereine et une fois
arrivé sur place il a fallu s'adapter
forcément oui justement dans ce livre
vous nous plonger dans les coulisses de
l'hôtellerie de luxe puisque vous êtes
employé au carillon hôtel 4 étoiles à
baltimore là bas vous avez vécu le faste
et les demandes de complètement
fantaisistes des clients que vous
désignez d'ailleurs des personnes
exigent enfin oui c'est le mot qu'on
utilise dans le milieu effectivement
d'une personne exigeante mais oui
effectivement quand on travaille dans un
hôtel de luxe on sait qu'on va devoir
répondre à des demandes parfois
loufoques c'est pas toujours le cas mais
voilà quatre étoiles moi je travaillais
dans le service banque est donc bon ok
on reçoit on peut recevoir des
personnalités on peut recevoir
voilà des cio
ce genre de personne assez importante
donc forcément elles ont des demandes
très précises et ses règles dans le
milieu de l'hôtellerie on demande
d'anticiper les besoins de l'autre donc
c'était assez
c'était du challenge
et on découvre aussi donc le monde de
l'hôtellerie vu des employés vous faites
beaucoup d'heures supplémentaires est-ce
que vous pouvez nous parler un peu de ce
métier oui c'est vrai que c'est un peu
la volonté de ce livre effectivement de
parler de métier assez méconnu au final
et lorsqu'on rentre dans l'hôtellerie à
moi je ne savais pas avant mais c'est
vrai que c'est un métier assez de
passion parce que voilà particulièrement
l'hôtellerie de luxe parce qu'on arrive
dans des endroits qui sont très très
beau donc on oublie un petit peu quand
on arrive dedans moi je connaissais rien
au métier on se voit que le côté fast et
ensuite on commence à travailler et on
se rend compte que voilà on doit
travailler de 5 heures du matin à minuit
et parfois on devait revenir le
lendemain à 5h du mat aux condors très
peu il ya des périodes plus ou moins
physique on comme on dit en anglais et
c'est vrai que il ya un moment où on est
dedans on se sent fatigué mais d'un
autre côté on s'amuse moi j'avais
l'impression un peu travaillé à
disneyland ce que j'avais des collègues
qui étaient des formidables on rigolait
beaucoup mais ce qu'ils m'ont été
extrêmement fatigué et épuisé
ça se ressent on le voit dans le livre
mais est justement vous parlez des
employés vos collègues énormément de
nationalités différentes
ça vous a enrichi culturellement ouais
ouais ouais assez marrant parce que ça
c'était vraiment la volonté de lothey
qui venait chercher des européens pour
venir travailler dans leurs hôtels ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'aux états
unis il n'y a pas de formation hôtelière
à proprement dire enfants sont de
trouver des écoles hôtelières mais aux
états unis n'ont donc c'est vrai que oui
parce qu'on avait des néerlandais des
roumains
des indiens des chinois he vraiment ça
venait de tous les coins du monde et
lorsqu'on arrive là on doit s'adapter à
toutes ces personnalités
mais en même temps on est là on est dans
la jeunesse on on se comprend vite en
fait on est des compagnons d'infortuné
on arrive on arrive tous et on va vivre
la même galère
voilà on avait tous le même niveau et on
était tous
voilà peu importe les études qu'on avait
fait on arriver et on devait tous
apprendre le métier de sur place de cet
hôtel là en particulier mais j'ai fait
des rencontres formidables et si avec ça
ouvre l'esprit de rencontrer des
personnes qui viennent du monde entier
moi j'avais des idées très près qu'on
sût par exemple je le dis dans le livre
avec les roumaines dont je n'avais que
l'image
voilà de ce qu'on voit les roms ce genre
de choses et je me suis rendu compte que
ça n'avait rien à voir que c'était des
européennes voilà comme moi qui avait
grandi fait des études et on s'entendait
extrêmement bien on sort banlieue sud
vous êtes mais restait du coup une année
là bas finalement vous finissez par vous
acclimater 1 on le voit bien dans le
livre et vous rencontrez quelqu'un vous
avez même pu aussi voyager dans
différentes villes comme new york ou los
angeles
new york a c'est arrivé parce que j'ai
réussi à devenir volontaire pour la
fashion week de new york donc voila moi
j'ai toujours été un peu passionnée par
la mode et je cherchais un petit peu
comme mots-clés gré et nous l'en que
j'avais bien aimé faire je connaissais
pas je n'étais jamais parti à new york
et donc j'ai postulé voilà personne ne
me répond et puis à force quelqu'un me
dit venez passer un entretien voilà pour
faire du volontariat pour la fashion
week de new york donc j'arrive à new
york et là effectivement l'impression
d'être dans un film on voit tout ce
qu'on a vu depuis qu'on est petit les
taxis jaunes la 5e avenue times square
et tout ça et
j'ai adoré un an après vous revenez en
france le retour à cette vie en ile de
france c'était un peu compliqué c'était
dur c'était dur parce que j'avais vécu
tellement de choses d'ailleurs plus ou
moins belles mais j'avais vécu
énormément de choses et ensuite quand on
revient moi je dis souvent à mes amis
j'ai besoin d'au moins six mois pour me
ré acclimater parce que
l'impression d'être dans une bulle en
fait à l'étranger puis on revient dans
notre quotidien donc on doit réapprendre
les mythes la communication avec nos
propres amis et parfois même avec la
famille c'était assez compliqué mais
voilà après avec le temps on revoit les
gens ont refait des activités on retombe
dans la vraie vie tout simplement les
des fois ça peut être un peu déprimant
et donc peut-être c'est pour ça aussi
votre envie de voyager de nouveau avoir
partait une nouvelle fois odette aligner
le bal colorado donc vous décrocher un
poste dans un hôtel de 5 étoiles
finalement vous le quittez vous trouver
un autre emploi dans un spa à paris ses
livres montrent aussi votre force de
caractère et de détermination
des prix
c'est ce que je trouvais et peut-être
que c'est ce que vous avez voulu
peut-être montré dans le livre alors
dans le livre c'est vrai que je voulais
montrer particulièrement j'insiste
beaucoup sur le fait que moi je suis né
j'ai grandi à nanterre donc c'était un
milieu très modeste donc j'ai vécu dans
une cité voilà qui est et ce qu'elle
était mais on en n'a survécu on peut
dire ça et c'est vrai que dans ce livre
j'essaie de montrer à une jeunesse
parfois qui ne sait pas trop où aller
que c'est pas grave quand fait en
poussant des portes on va finir par y
arriver en fait est qu'il ya d'autres
mondes à découvrir et que l'on des
grands on peut pas juste rester voilà
cantonner à ce qu'on connaît et à rester
dans sa zone de confort et que des fois
faut juste se donner la gnac il ya
beaucoup de belles choses qui peuvent
arriver
pourquoi justement choisir le monde du
luxe dans votre dans vos premières pages
on vous dit pas la moindre idée de ce
que je voulais faire dans la vie tout ce
que je savais c'est que ça devait avoir
un rapport avec le luxe oui oui parce
que alors quand je veux expliquer ça
voilà donc moi j'ai grandi dans un
milieu assez pauvre et le luxe en fait
je voyais ça un peu comme à monde il
atteignable mais comme j'aime beaucoup
des défis je me suis dit bon
tu connais ce milieu tu connais ce
milieu un peu modeste mais est ce que tu
peux atteindre ce niveau de vie au final
est ce que tu peux toucher au luxe à cet
inaccessible ce mystérieux pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs parce que je quand on voit à
la télé ou peu importe dans des
reportages on a l'impression que c'est
la vie qu'il faut c'est la vie facile la
vie voilà ben si demain je veux partir à
new york moi j'ai pas besoin de regarder
mon compte en banque pour savoir si j'ai
assez d'argent ce genre de choses et
alors c'est pas c'est pas une façon
d'être vénale moi je suis pas une
personne vénale dans le sens où voilà
avoir un sac louis vuitton ça
m'intéresse pas mais j'aime bien vivre
des expériences et pour moi c'est un
milieu du luxe qui allait m'apporter ça
il ya un chapitre dans ce livre nommé
deux anecdotes what the fuck
jean philippe schmid la cliente qui
refuse de dormir dans la même chambre
que son bébé à vous écrivez lorsqu'elle
arrive elle me demande quelle est la
politique de l'hôtel si on veut laisser
un bébé toute seule dans une chambre
donc c'est assez surprenant dans ce
livre il ya beaucoup d'anecdotes ans
comme celle ci vous pouvez nous en
raconter une qui n'est pas à citer dans
le roman alors là oui c'est vrai qu'il
ya pas mal de choses qui sont arrivées
il ya des petits trucs comme ça à part
dont je me souviens qu'à baltimore il y
avait un mariage indien voilà qui avait
coûté 1 million d'euros et la famille ce
genre de choses et alors il voulait
absolument avoir un cheval blanc pendant
le mariage donc mais le cheval blanc
devait rentrer aussi dans l'hôtel elle a
alors c'était tout un truc où est-ce
qu'on allait trouver un cheval lors à
baltimore filets par des chevals donc le
cheval est venu ensuite il peut aller
trouver comment l'emmener dans l'hôtel
mais après il fallait trouver comment
l'emmener dans l'ascenseur et c'est
l'hôtellerie de luxe est vraiment ça
c'est que on demande quelque chose et
ensuite il faut trouver la solution
parce que le client elle vit et sophie
il a demandé quelque chose il le veut et
donc
de ce voile à se réinventer de sacrément
de s'acclimater et
voilà de répondre aux exigences tout
simplement donc ça c'était une anecdote
assez rigolote oui c'est vrai qu'un
cheval blanc c'est tous les jours
et vous vous le dites dans
l'avant-propos c'est vraiment c'est
finalement votre journal intime pourquoi
avoir voulu écrire un livre finalement
ouais c'est un journal intime un journal
intime que j'ai j'ai tenu depuis je suis
tout petit et 5 1 lorsque j'écrivais
toutes ces parties là
je me suis qu'il avait peut-être quelque
chose à transmettre mais de le garder
pour moi c'était bien c'était un bel
exutoire mais qui avait peut-être un
message à donner aux autres donc c'est
pour ça aussi que j'ai commencé la
démarche de l'édition je l'avais écrit
pour moi je pense que mon nom écrit
toujours pour soi la base et ensuite on
se dit mais si ça peut toucher d'autres
personnes
voilà l'essayons
est donc ce premier roman que vous avez
écrit j'ai vu qu'il était aussi étudié à
l'université de princeton aux états unis
c'est une fierté j'imagine un car c'est
vraiment une fierté parce que encore une
fois c'est dans cette démarche de
vouloir
transmettre des choses et
particulièrement la détermination la
volonté de se dépasser et lorsque j'ai
proposé donc aux départements français
et italiens de l'université mon livre et
ils ont répondu présent quasiment
instantanément en disant mais
effectivement on a besoin de parler aux
élèves qui étudient inquiétudes des
français pour le coup de personnes comme
vous c'est à dire des personnes
on va dire de ma couleur les personnes
noires qui semblent dans la vie qui
viennent d'un milieu modeste qui arrive
quand même à pousser les portes et à
réaliser des choses sachant qu'en plus
il ya toujours une dimension différente
entre la vie entre guillemets des noirs
aux états unis la vie des noirs en
france et la directrice de département
me disais que les élèves de princeton
avait du mal à comprendre parce que pour
certains beaucoup venaient de milieux
modestes avaient du mal à comprendre
comment
une personne noire pouvait évoluer en
france parce que voilà ils ont leur
histoire la ségrégation ce genre de
choses et tout ça des systèmes qui sont
déjà en place comme la discrimination
positive et tout ça est demandé comment
nous en france on pouvait faire parce
qu'on n'avait pas toutes ses structures
pour nous aider et donc vous vous est
peut-être en train d'écrire un second
roman si
vous mettez pouvoir parler un peu
davantage pas tout car en fait il alors
quand j'ai créé ce livre il ya pas mal
de personnes qui montent mais où est la
suite parce qu'on a un livre sur la fin
et effectivement je dis que je pars au
japon donc j'ai décidé de décrire la
suite qui va raconter mes aventures au
japon où je suis devenu professeur
d'anglais on attend votre second roman
avec impatience merci beaucoup adama
sissoko d'avoir été notre invité et
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis et à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]